every fast and furious film has provoked
squabbles among fans and those squabbles
have only gotten bigger
as the franchise has grown from casting
decisions to plot twists
these are the times a fast and furious
franchise outraged fans the most
every fast and furious movie is a micro
time capsule
of what was hot in popular culture at
the time of its filming
the original film was in the dead center
of a time when light washed jeans
hollister shirts
and massive aftermarket spoilers were a
significant part of the culture
the early films were so beholden to
trends that they made an entire movie
without the original cast
just to cash in on the surging
popularity of a japanese racing style
the casting of dwayne the rock johnson
was an unquestionably smart decision
but will also serve as a glimpse of a
time when the wrestler turned actor was
coming into the peak of his box office
powers
i thought so other casting decisions
didn't receive the same sort of love as
johnson's
fans absolutely lost it when they
realized that rapper iggy azalea
played a small part in furious 7 and
they took to the internet to vent about
it though the part was inconsequential
and the film was still a hit
some people admitted it made them
properly angry
glasgow is a working class city full of
the exact kind of folks that would
delight in the fast gangs constant
heists
from greedy companies however being a
worker means having to get up in the
morning
and the shooting of fast and furious 6
made that more than a little difficult
according to reports from the daily
record locals were furious about two
weeks of nighttime filming
that included loud car based stunts
explosions and gunfire
it took hombraj at the fact that they
had not been warned of the night shoot
until right before they began
and complained repeatedly glasgow's film
office painted a different picture
saying that the film crew behind the
movie had given residents ample warning
at least the stunts looked good on the
big screen while most franchise fans
would be ecstatic at the idea of a new
film
a number of people in the fast fanbase
thought it was crass when the franchise
opted to continue
after the death of a core cast member
given the focus on family
quite a few fans were angry when fate of
the furious was announced as the eighth
film in the series
continuing the series without paul
walker didn't sit right with people who
had followed the franchise from
small-scale drag racing caper
to international gang of car driving
superheroes
some fans claim they would never see the
film while others simply worried on
social media that carrying gun after
walker's emotional send-off
would cheapen the ending of furious
seven still fate was a hit and the ninth
film was announced after its release
fate of the furious gave fans more
reason to be angry than paul walker's
absence
the plus of the eighth installment in
the series pitted dominic tiretto
against his surrogate family which the
trailers made clear
since the movies or stress the
importance of created families and
friendly bonds
antareto has put his life on the line
countless times to save his crew
dom turning his back on that and even
threatening to kill his friends
sparked anger when the trailer was
released fans wondered aloud why the
franchise would take such a turn
particularly in the wake of the loss of
paul walker in the real world
and the loss of friendly characters like
han within the fast universe
for certain viewers it felt like the end
of a beloved story
you lost the minute you interrupted my
honeymoon
of course it was later revealed that
dom's turn in fate was only part of a
blackmail scheme
by the end of the film he'd returned to
his family defeated the bad guys
and even made time for a cookout with
all his friends
han didn't need to be avenged but fans
couldn't have known that
since furious 7 we've been operating
under the assumption that the fan
favorite character
died at the hands of deckard shaw the
mercenary who arrived in that film to
avenge his brother's own defeat
in fast and furious 6. shaw's quest for
vengeance began with han whose seemingly
fatal crash all the way back in tokyo
drift was revealed to be the same crash
that launched deckard's fight
against the toretto crew in a
cliffhanger scene from fast and furious
6.
then came fate of the furious and the
revelation that deckard shaw was not
only walking free after han's death
but actually becoming part of the
toretto gang he even landed his own
spin-off alongside dwayne johnson's
character luke hobbs
who may not have been the most important
member of the toretto crew
but his death was still supposed to mean
something and letting shaw just get away
with it
inspired what's become known as the
justice for han movement among fans
something that will now be addressed in
f9 with the fast universe continuing to
expand
some of the sniping over the films is
coming from inside the franchise
following fate of the furious series
star tyrese gibson
tore into the production of hobbs and
shore the first movie outside of the
franchise's main timeline
saying that the film was not worth
splitting from the official series
in a now deleted instagram post after
the spin-off was released
gibson tore into the film's box office
numbers and this attempt at quote
breaking up the family he also offered
the opportunity for hubs and short stars
dwayne johnson
and jason statham to return for fast
turn to give quote
true fans what they wanted gibson's
comments only serve to stoke reports of
onset feuding between himself
johnson statham and vin diesel at the
moment
everyone seems to be happy with the
direction of their careers
but who knows what the future might hold
as the main furious series
reaches its end check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movie franchises are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you